Yeah.
Good morning, folks. It's...
Great to have a nice group like this.
And let's get moving.
My name is Harvinder JABBAL.
You can see my name on the slide.
And I'm going to introduce this course
called Software Architectures to you.
No.
Those of you who are attending a class
with Bits Pilani for the first time,
could you please put up your hands?
Okay.
VIVEK night. Oh, God. Oh, so.
That's great. It's an induction of sorts.
I'm privileged. I'm privileged.
So I'm finding such a large group of
people who are attending the first class
and bits and.
Saturday morning and I'm connected with
you. Okay, great. In which case I need to.
..
Introduce.
Of course.
Yeah.
K.
Since the number is not very large.
The total attendance is only
seventy-eight ;
I'm going to give permission for people
to speak, but...
Yeah.
And I'll also allow cameras.
I will take away this permission if I
find that too many people.
A creating a.
Problem, OK, so find.
So much for the hands that went up.
I can.
LAL.
Let me tell you that I will introduce
only this course and you can apply the
same to any other course.
This course will be conducted over 32
hours.
Of 16 sessions, 2 hours per session.
The.
Objective of this course is to help you
become more useful to the organisation in
which you work.
This is a work integrated programme, so...
You are all pre-employed.
Pre-employed means you already have
employment.
You are not doing this course to get
employment.
You are doing this course to further your
career prospects.
Software Architectures.
is one of those courses which is endless.
As you go through the course,
you will wonder.
Why such a course exists,
but it's a fantastic course to get an
overview of the.
Software industry,
what software systems are,
what software is.
And almost every session in this course.
Is conducted as a full-fledged course
with many of the sessions,
many of the items which you will learn
here are conducted as full-fledged
courses by BITS Pilani, so...
You'll be going through a gamut of a
number of things.
When you attend a course at such a high
level of abstraction,
you expect to have a very wide field of
knowledge.
Understand where things fit in without.
even trying to understand the details.
So whatever area you belong to,
you may try to understand the details,
the details of that item.
Like if you are into database,
you'll understand database.
If you are into hardware,
you'll understand hardware.
If you're an application developer,
you'll understand applications.
Evaluation.
As far as I'm concerned, as a faculty,
I'll be treating it as only as a means to
engage you with the course.
My intention is not trying to evaluate
you.
If you get evaluated in the process well
and good,
but the problem with the evaluation is
that.
It.
is sometimes very biassed.
My son, this is it.
The evaluation you are provided evaluates
you only in a particular dimension,
irrespective of how good evaluation is.
It cannot take care of every dimension of
evaluation. Yet,
evaluation promotes you try to study the
subject,
try to understand it in more detail.
And in the process, you learn something.
So don't get obsessed with evaluation.
Don't ask me to give you guest questions,
try to help you get through the midterm
with better marks,
because BITS has got a relative
evaluation system.
If you are the best in the course,
by far the best.
Even with 30 out of 100,
you can get an egret.
Some faculty to appease students.
I don't know whether they do it
deliberately or it's in the nature or
students like it.
They may be giving very high marks and
people feel happy they've got a high mark.
You've got 8 on 10. But
There are courses and bits with an 8 and
10, you can get a C grade.
So it doesn't help you.
There are courses with a 40 or 50 or 100
can get you an A grade.
The grading is relative.
So what is important is you have to stay
with the group.
You should not get left behind alone.
That's very important.
If you stray from the group upward,
you can get a B grade.
If you stray downwards, you get a B grade.
And if the stray is very large,
you may get an even better grade.
So,
this is as far as understanding the
course is concerned.
Evaluation-wise, in this course,
we'll be having a very large number of
quizzes.
So, after every session, almost,
except for the first session,
you will be getting a quiz which will
have 15 questions to be attempted in 5
minutes.
If you like to attempt them,
but definitely go through the slides
before attending them,
you'll get a week's time,
and out of the some at least 14 quizzes I
will give you.
Only.
Eight or so will be a required to be a be
at fall,
so you will have a lot of redundant
quizzes.
If it is possible,
I might give you a quiz in the coming
week itself.
OK, there's something.
Srimati, you have just entered the course.
Could you just unmute and say hello?
Hello, everyone.
Hi, hi, sir. Good morning.
Hi, hi, yeah, morning to you. Yeah, hello,
hello.
Hi, sir, good morning.
What I wanted to say was that if you have
entered with a non WILP ID,
you are left waiting in the waiting room.
If you log in with your the bits ID,
you will not have to wait in the waiting
room. You'll enter the class directly.
I thought I'd just let you know that
because I suddenly saw somebody waiting
in the waiting room and allowed you entry.
OK, so will come all the same.
Yeah.
So, there are two supportwilpbits,
I guess, once.
So one of you joined just now and I'm
referring to that person. Okay. So let's,
is there any question anybody wants to
ask? You can unmute and shoot.
I've got no problem.
This is the first class. We can,
though we have a lot of material,
you can read it later.
But I would like to...
Miss answering any queries,
anything you wish to know about the
course, or...
What, as a faculty member,
I can explain to you, I would love to.
Yeah,
so you put some questions in the chat,
though you can unmute and speak directly
also.
Yeah, so let's say that the, yeah, yeah,
he's right.
Yeah, hi sir. Like that question was mine.
So I was asking that like you mentioned
that there will be 14 quizzes and only 8
are mandatory.
Right.
So if we attend more than 8,
then will the best out of those attended
SANKET.
Yes, yes, yes, right. Definitely,
definitely, definitely. Yeah,
will be considered?
Okay, so thank you.
but as far as the load is concerned,
you need to take only eight. And now,
since you asked me this question,
my recommendation is you appear for both,
because the purpose of the quiz is not to
evaluate you again.
Not really,
everybody gets very high marks in these
quizzes. The reasons are obvious.
There are only 15 questions, 5 minutes.
That's a lot of time if you have read
your slides. But people use Gemini,
ChatGPT, whatever. So obviously you say,
if you know, sir,
that we are going to use Gemini,
then why have these quizzes?
Obviously, the marks will be high.
The reason is that even in using Gemini.
you at least indulge in the quiz.
You go through the questions,
you look at them. And my recommendation,
and as you know,
I'm giving you a week to appear for the
quiz after the contact session.
So over the week, you know,
you're going to appear for the quiz.
I'm hoping that you will go through the
slides. So
My intention is just to engage you with
the course.
So if you look through the slides,
you've attempted,
and if you've attempted all 14,
the chances are that you've gone through
all the slides.
Because just before the exam,
you normally don't have enough time.
So if you go through one slide set every
week, it'll be good for you. Yep.
Anybody else?
Sir, this is Kausik.
Very good morning and good morning to
Yeah, yeah.
Hi, Kaushik. Hi, Kaushik.
everyone. Sir, my question is,
every every course, right,
Yeah.
or every every lecture will will have
certain reading material, or you know,
material to read, right?
And is it is it that the this slides will
Right, right.
be the material, or is there any?
Anything that you will recommend for each
of the systems,
like how the learning material or reading
material will be given?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, Kaushik, it's like this.
This course is endless.
Yeah.
You can pack up your job.
You can take back up all the other three
courses and study just software
architecture. There's so much of content,
so...
My suggestion to you is that you follow
the 18-20 rule,
popularly known as the Pareto Principle.
Yeah.
Divide your plane,
decide to give a certain amount of time
to studies. Out of that,
decide to give a certain amount of time
Mhm.
to this course. And in that time,
the number one priority should be going
through the slides.
Okay.
Okay, okay, so.
After going through the slides,
if you have some time.
If you have missed my class,
go through my session in fast forward and
run it in two weeks.
You'll finish the two-hour session in
maybe one hour. Okay? I mean, this time,
because you can skip parts of it.
Okay.
And most of my contact sessions,
I will try to be interactive.
So there's a lot of wastage of time.
But if you have the time,
definitely do come for the session.
If you still have time left,
if you still have time,
Absolutely, sir.
I'll be recommending a textbook.
Read the textbook.
Got it, sir.
and go through the textbook,
at least for the fundamentals.
After the midterm exam,
the textbook will be of little use.
Okay.
You'll have to look up the internet.
So what you do is take the slides,
whatever you don't understand.
Gemini it or ChatGPT it.
Ask them to give you some information and
the most important thing is be overall
aware of the subject.
So a typically what I tell people is that
you take the slides,
feed it to ChatGPT and tell ChatGPT,
give me some practical problems on this
with the solutions.
read through them. You know,
you'll get a very good idea of,
because this course is so wide,
you simply cannot do 100% justice to it.
APARNA.
But if you do 20% justice to the course,
you'll probably be the cost hopper.
Okay.
Yeah, sure, sir. Thank you so much.
Yeah,
so Anupam Sorkar had something to ask.
Yes, sir. So a couple of questions.
So this slides that you would be sharing
Yeah.
on the present, I mean, on the session,
would it be available in the Elan portal?
Right.
They will be normally available before
the class in the eLearn portal from next
class onward.
But the moment I have presented the slide
over here, you go into MS TEAMS,
go into this course,
go into the file system,
and you find that the slide has already
got copied.
The way in which I do the presentation,
the slides go into the MS TEAMS folder
automatically. So if you take a look,
it's already there.
Okay.
And it would be under which tab?
See, see, you go into the into the course,
going to the MS TEAMS,
going to team teams, going to the course,
you select the course,
Yeah.
the course is Software Engineering.
The software architecture.
Yeah.
OK, under Software Architectures,
you will find on the right hand side.
Shared.
Share, OK.
Oh, okay, I can see the slide. Okay, yeah.
Class, it's already gone there by itself.
I've done nothing about it.
Okay, okay. And the quizzes, sir,
where it will be held, it will be again.
Because.
The quizzes will come in Taxila.
It'll be in Taxila. It'll be in Elan,
Pilani.
right? We call it Taxila.
Sure, thank you, sir.
Right, and...
Hi, sir. Renuka said one question. So,
as part of this, you know, subject,
Yeah.
will we be having some sort of projects
will be like, you know,
design based projects like that?
Right.
What happens is that the assignments you
will have will be very, very basic,
very basic. Absolutely,
Yes, sir.
they won't be of industrial scale at all.
Okay.
And assignment one will be just to give
you an idea of how to present an
architecture.
at a very simple level,
because I know for a fact that you all,
in fact, in this course,
I have not gone through your profiles
just now,
but generally I find that the average age
of people here is about 10 years of work
experience.
And I always find a few people who have
worked for over 30 years attending this
course.
So,
with this type of a varied and a talented
pool of people.
You know,
there's little point in trying to...
Ohh.
Fuller out.
So...
The.
People know what they're doing,
they know why they're doing it.
So...
How could I be more precise in answering
your query?
Thank you, sir.
So it's a great exposure and people know
what they want to do.
So if I take the project too advanced,
it becomes a bit of a problem.
In assignment 2, however, we do.
A very nice thing in this course,
we group you into groups of 20, 25 people.
And before the group activity starts,
we ask you to submit individual
assignments.
After sharing the individual assignments,
we ask you to share it with your group
members after the due date is over.
Say we close that assignment on 15th,
from 16th,
you have to share it with your group.
group members,
we announce the groups and we ask you to
share it to the group.
We let you know how you share it.
And then we have an online discussion
through eLearn Portal with your group
members, which is observed by everybody.
So
The whole idea is that these very
experienced people I'm talking about,
they share their knowledge with a small
group.
And though you can participate only in
your own group,
you'll be able to see the interaction in
other groups.
So you'll get an opportunity to see a
very large number
of assignments done by so many people.
So that's an area where you will get some.
Practical sort of an exposure,
and this whole course, you know,
it's a very practical course.
K.
Yeah.
But now, what? Good morning.
Good morning, Seth.
Uh, sir, uh, with reference.
Put up your hand and speak, please. Ajit,
I know, I know it's Ajit, but still,
before you start speaking,
just put up your hand.
It's easier for me to identify. Yeah,
Ajit, tell me.
Okay, sir, okay, sir.
Okay, okay. Yeah. Sir,
with reference to the book,
so in the handout,
there are two books mentioned. Yeah.
Lynn, Lynn,
Lynn is the more important one. OK, Lynn,
OK, OK, yeah, thank you.
OK.
Just a sec,
some people have recording will be made
immediately or after a few days,
immediately.
The moment we close the session,
the process is automated.
Is the exam date already decided?
It is already decided,
but I don't have it directly available.
You'll come to know.
I can share it to you next week.
K.
Then that was a SAMPATH Kumar, right?
And Sambat Kumar, I could,
since this is the first time you are
attending a course,
we have 8 sessions before the midterm.
So from this Saturday, count 8 Saturdays.
And including the Independence Day
weekend, and on the 9th, Saturday, Sunday,
Okay.
on the exam. OK,
so I'm just giving you a rule of thumb.
Thank you.
And then you'll have another eight
sessions, two weeks of exam,
another eight sessions,
and then you'll have your comprehensive
exam.
So that takes care of SAMPATH Kumar's
query.
So that take Rakesh's query also.
And there was somebody.
****.
Umesh Kumar.
Ohh.
That's a very interesting name.
My father used to have a friend whose
name was George Taylor.
So, I wish Kumar Taylor.
So he was,
George Taylor was the Britisher.
And he was a very prominent person in the
locality where we used to live. Okay,
so Mish wants to know about the watermark.
You'll get a watermark copy of the slide
just before the comprehensive exam.
and they will be PDFs.
And you will be only allowed to take a
printout of that and take for the exam.
So the slides you are getting now are
without a watermark.
AMITESH, can I hear your voice?
Yes, yes sir, I understood. Okay,
I thought that okay,
Okay.
if it will be ready now itself,
so we can keep it printed and then
Yeah, yeah.
eventually the same we can take it.
Yeah, yeah, we used to do that,
but our management seems to be having
some problem with that.
They want to announce a unique watermark
E.
every semester.
Okay.
So they will announce a watermark only
maybe a week or two before the
comprehensive. And at that time,
you will be allowed,
you can take a printout.
The midterm exam is closed book.
The comprehensive is open book.
Yeah, yeah,
but but like if we if we keep reading
Okay, yeah.
from those prints, right,
then it will be better, but yeah, I...
Right.
Yeah, okay. Yeah,
I'll just tell you something about that
in a minute. Let me see.
BOTLA has got the answer.
Mhm.
Rahul,
could you please guide us with the scope
of syllabus that we are going to study?
Rahul, could I hear you?
Hi, sir.
Hi, RAHUL,
can you state your question for me?
What type of answer are you expecting?
Thank you, sir, but my name is RAJ,
and I just wanted to know, like,
Okay, okay.
what are the topics we are going to cover
in this area, like, in for this subject?
Okay.
Like, as you said, it is a vast subject.
OK, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
very good, good question,
Yeah.
and I'll just take it up.
OK, yeah, I think of...
Do you want to know the topics?
And, uh, Umesh,
what had you wanted to know?
Ohh.
Yeah, the the watermark PPT, like,
as you already said,
No, that's not true.
that it will be present at the end of.
Yeah.
Mmh.
There was some other questions which I
said I'll try to take up later.
RAJ, I said,
I'll explain it in more detail later.
Regarding the watermarks.
Watermark is all right, yeah, watermark.
Huh, let's put it this way. Yeah,
this is what I wanted to tell you.
That you know, an open book exam,
for many of you,
it might be a first time experience.
Closed book exams, you understand.
Open book exam is very funny.
It is one of those exams where,
without the book open, you can't answer,
and at least you've studied the material,
you can't use the book that you open up.
And as a teacher,
they are the most difficult papers to
cheque because nobody leaves the answer
paper blank.
They simply copy a part of the notes that
they are carrying with them. So normally,
you know,
when a person is calculating bold with
the question paper,
you don't know what to write.
But we find that with an open book exam,
people write something.
Will it answers the question or not? Now,
you've got to be very,
very focused while answering an open book
question.
Remember one thing: you're copying from
notes.
Even the teacher knows you are copying
from notes,
so just copying will not help you.
You have to address the question very
precisely.
You've got to understand the question and.
..
give an answer which is relevant to the
question.
So this is what I wanted to warn you. Now,
what about the topics?
The topic sem.
And this is for RAJ.
So.
We will start this course by telling you
what is architecture,
we'll try to define architecture,
and then we'll gradually go on to explain
how to present architecture.
After we've learned how to present
architecture,
we will understand what are the tactics
involved in achieving certain end results.
After we learn the tactics,
we will learn patterns.
And then after we learn patterns,
we will see the modern application of the
patterns and modern architectures like
mobile architecture, cloud architecture,
and trends in IoT devices.
in embedded technologies.
So a glimpse on these things,
modern ways of handling operations.
So this is the way we will proceed with
the course. So RAJ,
does that give you an overview of the
course?
Yes, Sir.
Okay,
now there are some more people who have
their hands up. We've got to give them a.
Pratyush.
Yeah, hello, sir. Sir,
my question is regarding the study
Like, welcome.
strategy,
and would you recommend making notes for
this subject in this era?
See, Pratyush,
it's a bit of a personal question.
How many years have you been working?
Okay.
3.5, 3 1/2.
3.5. Okay. 3.
5 is not too much and not too little
either. Okay.
If you had told me you have been working
for 10 years, I would have told you.
Are you still in a position to take notes?
It becomes very difficult to write after
sometime when you're in this industry now.
Whether you write, you make drawings,
or you simply read,
it's a very personal style.
For example, when I was in college,
I was a proud owner of a typewriter.
Very few people had typewriters those
days. I had a typewriter.
So when I used to come back from class,
I used to spend the whole evening typing
all the notes. Okay, it helped me.
It did me good. I had typed copies and...
my type copies were in big demand for the
juniors.
They wanted to get a copy of my notes.
Some people like to draw sketches,
you know, whatever.
Some people simply like to read.
They feel that they can cover much more
if they read.
So this is a very personal style,
but all I can tell you is...
Try to cover as much as you can.
Don't try to remember too much in this
course, OK?
Yeah, the density.
Next would be Mouli, Chandra Mouli.
Yeah, hi, sir. Good morning. Good morning.
Good morning.
Right, welcome.
So as you mentioned,
we'll be having 14 quizzes and eight of
them will be considered, right?
Yeah,
you need to appear for only eight of them.
And if you appear for extra,
we'll take the best.
Okay.
Similarly,
how many assignments should be have for a
new subject for each one step?
In this course, see, course to course,
there'll be a variation.
Even quizzes die in most of the courses,
you have only two quizzes or three
quizzes. Okay, and all are complete.
It's only in this course that you do it
Okay.
Yeah.
like this.
I've taken special permission to do it
Okay.
like that. Assignment for this,
in this course,
We'll be having two assignments.
Okay.
One will be before the midterm,
one will be after the midterm. Okay.
OK, two are mandatory, right?
And that's only for this course.
And they are mandatory. Mandatory,
Okay.
you've asked a very tricky question.
I hope you, mandatory is a very,
A aec.
very tricky word to have used.
Would you explain to me what mandatory
means or should I explain to you?
Yeah, no, like, as...
See, the only thing that is mandatory,
the only thing that is mandatory is the
midterm exam and the comprehensive exam.
If you do not appear for those exams,
you do not complete the course.
Okay.
All the other evaluation components are
optional, but if you don't,
And...
Okay.
you get a zero.
OK,
and I got to know from my peers or from
my from the batch mates,
so I got to know that if we try to score
Yeah.
more of the marks and the assignments or
the quizzes,
there will be a high chance we have the
may turn on the exams.
Mm.
Beg your pardon?
If you...
Like,
if you try to attempt the quizzes on the
assignments at your best.
WILP.
Hmm.
Then there would be a high chance to
clear the mids and the,
and there will be a high chance to score
the better the.
Let's put it this way: if you do your
quiz and your assignment,
you have more or less cleared the course.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
And if you don't appear for the midterm
and the assignments,
it's like committing suicide.
Yes.
You might as well go and lie down under a
railway track as far as the course is
concerned,
because those are the easiest pieces to
score, but they are not mandatory. OK,
that's why I was laughing on the use of
Okay.
the word mandatory.
Of.
So, okay, they are optional.
You don't feel like a period,
don't appear for any assignment,
don't appear for any quiz,
and you can appear for the exams and you
can still clear the course.
But if you miss the midterm and the
makeup, that's the end of the course.
Bye.
Yeah.
You'll have to repeat it in another
semester.
Okay.
Sure, thanks for the input.
Goa.
Yeah, okay, Chandrasekar.
And.
Hello, sir. Good morning. So,
I have shown a series of experience in IT.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
I have just gone through a few slides
Right.
before joining this call,
so it's moreover looks like a system
Right.
design course.
So, what my question is like,
in today's world,
Mm.
everything is integrated with AI,
so when it comes to architecture,
Mm.
so are we are we going to touch base on
AI things as well, like?
We are not going to talk about designing
AI systems or large models,
but we'll definitely talk a little about
AI at the end of the course.
And Chandrasekhar,
since you said you're working for seven
Yes.
years,
in which area have you been working?
Yeah.
So, I'm working as a DevOps engineer.
Okay, great. Now,
let me tell you a little bit about,
it's a part of what I would have taught,
but let's do it right in the beginning.
See, you have architecture,
you have system design,
Yep.
you have got coding idioms.
Architectures is the course model.
System design is the detailed design of
the application.
Okay, yeah.
Okay.
We will not even touch it in this course.
Okay, sure, yeah.
We'll be only talking about the macro
model.
All right.
The interaction between subsystems.
Okay, yeah.
What happens inside a subsystem and how
the code is written and where we talk
about, we expect you to know.
We expect that even if you don't know,
you will look up a little bit on the
internet.
and find out what UML is,
but we will not teach you UML in this
course.
Any system design course would have
taught you UML.
Okay.
And you have done a course in system
design somewhere, right?
Ohh.
So you would have studied class diagrams,
system sequence diagrams,
sequence diagrams, collaboration diagrams,
student diagrams,
Uh, yes, sir, so...
all that is not in this course. Okay.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, so welcome. Yes, separate, separate.
OK, thank you, sir.
So yeah,
my question is basically around how much
deep we are going to go on in terms of
software architecture.
In terms of I can see the curriculum and
it seems to be on a fairly,
Yeah.
on the topics point, it seems to be very..
.
A straightforward basic things like what
are different kind of models in terms of
architecture, publishers, scribe,
clients of a broker is that, but,
Yeah, right, right, right.
but let's say if I am hoping to get my
TOGEF certification,
let's say in one or two years, so,
so how much?
Okay. Okay.
This course will help me to get the
groundwork done.
How many years have you put into this
line already?
Thank you.
At 22 years.
Oh,
so let's put it this way: you are in
Mm.
competition with people who are who have
been appearing for lots of exams recently.
The type of exams you are appearing for
are totally different, very practical,
Yep.
focused on certain technologies. OK, now..
.
Discourse.
You have to control your temptation of
getting too deep.
So like you said, that various models,
we call them patterns.
Mhm.
So awareness of the patterns.
And then if you have the time and the
Yeah.
interest, look up individual examples.
But we will not insist that you go into
these individual examples.
You can stay at the surface.
But anybody who feels like going deeper,
Most welcome,
because when the examination comes,
your ability to apply what you have
learnt into an application is very useful.
Now, there's a small problem.
The exam might ask you a question from a
particular domain,
and there it is like a lucky tip.
If you're aware of the domain,
you'll understand the question better and
you'll understand the approach better.
And if you've already experienced that
domain,
you'll know what would be a good practise
in that domain.
But if you have understood the concepts
properly,
you will be able to formulate your own
solution.
So a person like you will be able to
understand the problem and take a look at
it from a distance.
A person who's about one or two years in
the line.
will get overhauled with the course,
will get absolutely scared.
How am I supposed to do so many things?
The moment you told me that it looks as
if it is very basic,
it simply means that you're looking at it
from the top of a 30-story building.
And that's the way you go to look at this
course.
So.
Yeah, sure, sure. Thank you very much.
Yeah, yeah,
Answer it, that's OK. OK, yeah, yeah.
and and during during the courses,
we will means to we will get some kind of
a scenario-based questions also,
so that we can.
Yeah, it will be totally scenario based.
Almost everything will be scenario based.
Okay, thank you. Thank you, sir.
Okay, and by the way,
I'll tell you one thing.
BITS has got an application for creating
question papers which uses AI.
Okay.
So the faculty doesn't have a complete
choice. The syllabus is fed in,
Okay.
the textbook is fed in,
and the question generated by the model,
Uh-huh.
and the faculty has got some choices.
We are allowed to feed in some diagrams,
but that AI model generates a question.
We are supposed to choose all of those
questions and then polish them up. Okay.
Okay, got it.
So even that way,
which is up to date with technology. Now,
I'll tell you about myself. I'm sorry,
I've not,
I cannot take an introduction from all of
you,
It.
but I need to briefly at least tell you
who I am. My name is Harvinder JABBAL.
And I did my engineering during the days
when there was no branch called computer
science. Okay.
The first degree in computer science in
India was offered in BITS Pilani.
before the IITs, in fact,
two years after I passed out.
During our days,
if you wanted to study computers,
you had to study electronics.
And getting admission in electronics at
BITS Pilani was considered like winning a
lottery ticket.
And I was one of those lucky people to
have won that lottery ticket.
I did buy electronics from BITS Pilani.
And by now, you would have guessed that.
I'm fairly ancient.
Right.
Sethi, since you worked for 22 years,
can you take a guess when that would have
been? If it is before the days of...
Around I would say 98 or...
Yeah, 98,
you don't have the guts to say what it
Okay.
actually is. I passed it in 78.
Oh my god.
So, I'm very in chat. Okay. So,
I passed in 78.
All right.
I worked for two corporates and after
working for two corporates,
I found my own consulting company because
I did my management after that.
And I formed a consulting company to do
management consulting.
But landed up getting computer
assignments because right from my college
days, I had done a good bit of coding.
I used to code in Fortran those days,
but when I got into the commercial world,
I had to learn COBOL.
And thereafter,
it was one language after the other,
and I stayed with coding because my
company got assignments mostly in the
area of software development.
I started trying to close this company
around 10 years back.
And I'm being a bit unsuccessful because
some old clients don't want to pack up.
So I have some people working from home.
We try to do some assignments.
But I try to stay off work,
but I'm not really quite off work.
I'm still at work.
BITS Pilani ever since I passed out,
except for the six years of corporate
working when I could not be engaged with
BITS.
The moment I started my own activity,
BITS involved me in the education
programme and I've been teaching for the
BITS WILP programme since 1985,
continuously till today.
as earlier as an adjunct faculty and now
as a guest faculty.
So.
I have been developing software even
today. I am a hands on KOHAD. OK,
so put on all sorts of work and now happy
to be engaged with you.
Yup.
So...
Ohh.
The end is asking me what study strategy
should be recommended for someone first
online class while working.
Just read through the slides,
go through the slides.
And if you don't understand something,
Google it or look up some.
One of these AI tools.
Oh.
Thank you.
RAJ RAHUL,
I'm happy that you got in touch with the
right people who felt like recommending
this course, so you're welcome, of course,
so...
Really, Anupam,
you're quite senior than if 78 is your
birth year. Okay.
No, I think it was eighty-five, you said,
when you started with, uh, for...
The.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, okay, okay. 85.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. Yeah,
Yeah.
I've got children who were born about
that time. My eldest daughter is 82 born.
My youngest son is 89 born.
And I'm delivering this lecture from my
son's house.
I'm currently located at Canada.
And my time is...
11.33 PM. I'm still on the 24th.
India is always ahead, you know.
Jola started 25th. I'm on 24th.
So it is late in the night for me. Yeah.
Yeah.
So that's it.
Midterm final, both happen on Saturdays,
Sundays only, in just two days,
all four exams.
Something which I should not recommend,
and I do not recommend,
you have 4 exams in two days.
Ohh.
Many people.
Find some excuse to take two exams
regular and two exams make up.
It's a dangerous practise because there's
no makeup for makeup.
If you really fall sick or you have a
problem with the makeup,
you can't take a makeup air off.
But even people who are very close to me,
I find them appearing 2 + 2 and well,
I'm nobody to advise.
So that's how it is.
In fact,
my son did this course many years back.
And.
The M.
Tech he did was definitely counted when
he applied for his PR to Canada.
Of course, he's now a Canadian citizen,
but...
He did the sem tech and.
He had his own strategy of studying,
so I've had opportunity to see students
in my home. In fact, in my own family,
among my children, or my in-law,
children-in-law,
I've got three BIT students alumni.
So I'm quite attached to this programme
and I find it's a good way to enhance
your exposure.
So.
Let's quickly go through some slides,
though we'll fall behind,
but we'll make up in the future sessions.
There's...
Nothing to really get.
Too concerned about?
I will obviously be giving more priority
to interaction than to covering the
slides because I know the slides are
available to you.
You can always go through them.
So.
Here, you've seen this list, and you know,
I normally when I'm presenting the slides,
I...
Allow the sharing, say, for example,
if I want you to see the...
If I want you to...
Ohh, just a minute.
Now, you have,
I've aligned you all into the slide I am
seeing.
Okay.
And now you are allowed to move forward
or backward.
This is a feature of MS TEAMS that I
really like.
And I'd like you to be able to see,
go ahead and see slides from other pages.
So, you've seen this?
If you think you need to know,
you may read through why.
Software Architectures is important.
This is.
As for Lynn Bass,
why is Software Architectures important?
For architecture to work,
you need individual competence,
technical knowledge, skills,
organisational competence,
and organisation having the capability to.
work with standardised processes,
with Architectures, with governance,
and you need a framework.
So you have a framework where the duties,
skills, and knowledge are defined.
I'm just going to run through the 84
slides,
and I'm going to go slow on a few of them.
So, these are things which...
You could see it through on your own.
I want to touch on this early design
decision. See,
what does the ARCHITA look at?
Firstly,
let's understand who is the architect.
Normally,
an architect is a very senior person in
the organisation.
Acha BOTLA SINDHURA.
Uhh.
Our examination,
if there are eight sessions,
the questions will be balanced between
the eight sessions and there will be no
choice.
Many other universities give you 6
questions, answer any four.
BATS gives you no choice in the question
paper.
If there are three questions or six
questions, you have to answer all of them.
And there will definitely be.
A question on every part of the syllabus,
so selective study is not going to be
possible, OK?
If you leave out some topics.
based on the course handout.
You just might have run a blank when it
comes to the exam.
So my recommendation is,
and even for a practical work point of
view,
if you want to utilise this course as
knowledge for the future,
you should have a basic knowledge of the
entire course rather than trying to get
detailed knowledge on a few.
topics.
So what I would recommend is see this 84
pages of slides is quite a bit.
Just go through them,
at least see the titles.
And if you don't understand the title,
read through a bit of that.
OK, so.
What lesson?
Good day.
Get in. Does that answer your question?
I'm getting here, Portla, SINDHURA, OK.
I expect you to unmute and see something.
SINDHURA.
Okay, you have issues with the mic. Fine,
perfect.
Try to correct it next time if you can,
or you can get in on your mobile and say
hi. Of course,
I hope your mobile supports the latest MS
TEAMS. MS TEAMS become a big problem.
There are people who have to buy new
phones only.
To take care of MS TEAMS running that, OK,
so...
These are very senior people and they
normally get involved in the beginning of
the course.
on the beginning of the assignment. Now,
why at the beginning of the assignment?
Because at the beginning of the
assignment,
you've got to take major decisions of
allocation of resources,
how you will approach a problem,
what will be the strategy.
And it's almost like saying that it's
like building the foundation of a
building.
If you've taken those decisions correctly,
you will reap the fruit right through the
project.
If you take some wrong decisions at the
beginning, you're going to pay for it.
The architect decides what decisions you
have to take now and what decisions you
can take later. And as a developer,
always delay decision making.
Everybody says, no, no, no,
take your decisions early. No,
delay your decisions.
Only freeze your decisions that need to
be frozen at a particular point of time.
Which means if you have a project,
there's certain things you have to freeze
right in the beginning.
Whether you're going to have distributed
storage,
you're going to have centralised storage.
Whether you're going for a web
application or you're going for a thick
client Windows application with
application running on individual clients.
How will you distribute the services,
whether they run on separate servers,
whether you'll have a content
distribution network or not?
Whether you will have...
What amount of data will be available
locally? What will be available remote?
What will be the technologies you will
use to deliver certain products? Now,
if you don't take this decision in the
beginning,
you cannot proceed with detailed design.
So early design decision is one of the
very important aspects of an architect's
job, and that is why
Architectures are normally senior people,
people with a wide exposure to projects
who understand the implication of the
decisions they take.
No.
We talk about constraints.
Whenever you have any project.
The other functions requirements.
The NFRs and the constraints.
Functional requirements,
we all understand.
Non-functional requirements,
50% of this class understands.
No.
Chandrasekhar, are you still there?
Okay.
I want to hear from anybody who's been
working for over 10 years.
So, so sorry.
Yeah.
That's Chandrashekar, OK.
Of.
Good morning, sir. So, the functional,
so I would say the functional requirement
Yeah, yeah.
is the requirement that actually the
business needs for, you know,
Note.
the business requirement, I would say,
where developer is focused more on the
business point from the business point of
view.
And the non-functional requirement is
something which is not coming from the
business. For example,
like a security software.
It's not something that is coming from
the business.
So an architecture involves these
non-functional requirements,
like how the secure software system
should look like.
So we will add it,
add those non-functional requirements
Okay.
during the design phase,
or sometimes we call as a design by
E.
privacy in the beginning of the
architecture planning.
So those are non-functional.
GAURAV,
you will definitely have a good number of
Okay.
years in your pocket.
Been working for quite a good period.
No.
Huh?
No, actually,
so it it it comes by learning,
so it's not that my I have the over 9
plus years of experience in the industry.
That's a decent bit. That's a decent bit.
It's not small because.
As you grow in the industry,
you start realising that what you're paid
Yeah.
for is more of the non-functional than
the functional.
Correct, correct. Yes, that's correct.
And what we as architects develop.
Design.
Sometimes it has something to do with the
functional requirements,
but it has got more to do with the
non-functionals.
Yeah, yeah.
And in this course,
our emphasis will only be with
You.
non-functionals and non-functions will
include, yeah.
Edition.
So, sorry, I heard my name,
so I thought you called me,
But.
OK, send this, yeah.
but I was speaking on mute actually. Yeah.
No, no, that's not great. So I asked you,
anyway,
Yeah, so...
we got another friend of ours to
participate. And you would have also, see,
the moment you have finished five,
seven years in the industry,
Yeah, yeah, so...
you become conscious about
non-functionals.
Yeah.
So when people join the industry,
Yeah.
They,
unless they get involved with performance
evaluation and they become performance
engineers,
or they get involved in certain aspects
of the software, cloud engineers,
you know, you have to,
you're forced to attend to
non-functionals. Otherwise, most people,
they start their career with functionals.
People who start their career with coding,
they will be going through system design,
Yep.
they'll be looking at the application,
understand the flow of the application,
they'll be writing down use case,
hearing use case stories,
and developing the application to
implement the story.
We'll talk about agile groups.
So, at a certain stage, they realise that,
OK, all this we are doing,
we are perfecting, but at the end of it.
It is the response,
the performance that the customer is
looking for.
It's the availability of the system that
he's looking for. It's the testability,
it is the maintainability,
it is the security,
it is the extensibility, interoperability.
Yeah.
And this is what the big money in the IT
industry is all about.
P.
Yeah.
Soon.
The architect,
the first job of the architect is finding
out non-functionals.
And you know why I'm spending time on
explaining this is this gives you a very
good idea of the perspective in which we
are talking about this course.
What happens is that...
Renu.
Focus on these non-functional
requirements.
You start realising.
DEEPAK.
The customer himself or herself,
the customer's representatives,
they do not seem to understand these
non-functional requirements very often.
Except, of course,
if they're very professional people who
have got a very solid IT backbone in
their company.
And sometimes there are people there who
understand,
but the company doesn't understand.
And the fact that for every bit of a
non-functional capability that you put in,
you have to put in an enormous investment.
And the money requires to be sanctioned.
And when you deliver,
you've got to prove that you have
achieved what you had committed.
So this is the whole game plan in
architecture,
that you first educate your customer,
and how do you educate it?
You have got your professional background
as an architect.
The company you're working in.
You have been implementing a certain type
of an architecture.
Say you are in a software development
house.
You all are normally comfortable with a
particular type of architecture,
so you tend to push that everywhere.
Then there are references in the industry.
You come to know that a certain approach
seems to work right.
You've studied patterns,
so you know what can be achieved with
what type of an architecture.
Then you implement it and you get success
of failure.
Success encourages you to follow that
again the second time.
So.
And then you explain to your customer
that, see, listen,
this is what we can do for you.
But if we do this.
Non-functional requirement,
you can't get everything that you dream
of.
If you have too much of security,
you might suffer in performance.
And customer has got to be made to
understand. And ultimately, customers,
as an architect,
you have to have a dialogue with the
customer to help the customer make
choices and then understand the
consequences of the choices.
and then sign on the choice they've taken
and then accept a product which conforms
to that requirement. So this is then.
Right in the beginning,
there may be certain constraints.
Besides the functional requirement and
the non-functional requirements,
there's certain constraints.
The constraint may be that the company...
is not willing to use any RDPMS rather
than Oracle. Okay, that's a constraint.
Constraint may be that they are not
allowing you to use a public cloud for
whatever purpose.
Constraint may be that the database must
be stored in certain countries.
You have to distribute.
The national requirements say India
requires that any data to do with any
user in India,
a copy must be there in India,
which the Indian court should be,
which should be under the jurisdiction of
Indian courts.
So these constraints the architect has
got to be aware of because the
architecture will be dependent on the
constraints.
So, I told you that the influences.
It will influence the organisation
structure.
It will enable evolutionary prototype
because once you have an outline,
everybody knows what is required. Okay,
folks,
there's another practise we will have.
After one hour,
we'll take a 10 minutes break.
So this have a 10 minutes break now.
We'll get back after the break.
You can also go and have some water or
whatever.
Okay, SAURAV LAHIRI had a question.
Mizul has answered it absolutely right.
Why go so far as to go to Europe?
Even the IT Act in India imposes
limitations. And it will be very similar.
It's regarding data protection.
The Indian government gave a lot of
trouble to some of the major.
giants who said that no,
it's not possible.
This is if Indian courts do not have
jurisdiction,
we will not allow your application to run
in India.
So the Indian court should be able to.
Give instructions and the process
improvement,
which we perform during the runtime of
project, we classified it in NFRs,
or is it a different concept altogether?
Generally,
we do it as a value addition to the
customer.
Not sure of whether you do it ab an issue
or you do it on a continuous basis. Now,
the...
Problem is that when you do value
addition.
And if you're touching the conceptual
basis,
you might have to revamp your entire
application.
But definitely, if you are...
re-engineering your application or you
are making architectural modifications,
we will go into the types of
modifications which we talk about as
architectural modifications.
If you have to do them immediately after
setting up the original application, well,
it is pure architectural design.
It will reflect on the architect.
When it comes to fine-tuning an
application and improving is working.
That's acceptable.
So the architecture should be designed in
such a manner that any changes that are
likely to be required in the next few
years.
can be localised to individual modules.
That would be a good architecture.
So you separate your application in such
a way that...
Any need that may arise,
even of a non-functional nature,
should not have an implication cutting
across multiple modules or subsystems.
If it does,
you might as well be reading the entire
app.
application. And things do happen.
There are changes that change in
technology, the way it works.
Suddenly people are having to reinvent
entire systems.
The life of the system is coming out much
shorter than was anticipated,
but then that's it.
So when we talk about it.
enabling evolutionary prototype.
Our ladies example could be.
A question of evolutionary prototypes.
See,
just now we spoke to somebody who says
he's working on DevOps.
DevOps is basically...
Going through evolutions,
you keep you continuously under upgrade
and you keep adding features,
you keep adding system,
but the overall architecture was decided
upfront.
And you did not go around making changes,
which is simply cut across the
architecture.
That would have been very poor design.
Texture.
Once it's frozen,
only then can you really work out the
costs and work schedule estimates if you
don't even know.
what your architecture is,
then you know you cannot proceed with
costing, you can't proceed with schedules.
Within an overall architectural framework,
minor changes here and there during
development is basically what we talk
about as agile practises.
You may have the change control board.
But for every little thing,
you're not going to have major
implications on the budget. Now,
companies work out certain business
models.
There could be labour cost models,
there could be a team which is dedicated
to improvement and the team along with
the say the product.
Manager of the product owner.
May decide as to what they will do under
each sprint,
and everybody works as a team.
But all this is possible once the
architectural framework has already been
established. Then you keep adding stories,
features,
the small enhancements here and there.
And that itself can have an enormous
organisation involved.
Transferable to reusable models,
if we create.
Applications that can be reused.
Using independent components,
even an architect has to give thought to
this, whether we will make or buy,
whether we will use existing components,
whether we will create components which
we can reuse all over the.
T.
Beauty with architecture is that it gives
us vocabulary.
If you want to discuss how we will...
solve a problem.
And the moment you have patterns,
you have tactics, you have a vocabulary.
One of the biggest earning from this
course for anybody who's registered in
the course will be improvement in your
vocabulary. And my suggestion would be,
you will see it happening even in CS2,
CS3.
There's so many words that are going to
come in, and many of you may say, "No,
we are familiar with these words."
Some of you may be familiar with the
words,
but may not be knowing the exact meaning.
I will not be able to cover each word in
detail here.
But each word signifies a tactic.
An approach,
so what is a tactic that understand in
decision making?
They have very few decisions which are
strategic.
There are lots of work which is tactical.
And then you have operation management.
Strategies would be patterns.
And when we talk about patterns here,
we are talking about architectural
pattern, not design patterns.
Many architectural patterns and design
patterns may have shared a common
vocabulary.
They'll be very similar to one another.
But the moment we talk about
architectural patterns,
we are talking about subsystems
interacting with each other.
When we talk about design patterns,
they are classes talking to each other.
Tactics based on a strategy,
The way you handle the strategy is
tactics, so...
For every little thing you want to do,
there are tactics available.
And given a situation,
you should be able to select tactics.
You must be familiar with the language
used to describe the tactics.
So that we call building up a vocabulary.
And whether or not you want an A grade or
any E grade in this course,
If you want to survive in this industry.
you might as well develop a good grasp of
the vocabulary which people use in
talking about decisions in architecture.
Then architecture is a basis for training.
The moment you have an architecture in
place,
you know what type of training is to be
offered,
who are the type of people you need to
recruit,
what talent transformation needs to be
done to make people capable to handle
things.
So,
you come to know which other individual.
types of activities that will be handled.
I won't stop at the summary.
The context.
The.
Technical context,
the project lifecycle context,
the business context,
the professional context.
So this is the context in which we see
architecture.
Technical is use of what technology,
what type of database.
How many years?
How will you go over the coding?
What programming language would be
suitable? Project life cycle is.
You talk about inception.
Elaboration.
Construction.
And you have deployment.
So, how do we go about it then?
When do you take major decisions?
Inception,
you have the outline of architectural
framework.
In the early phase of elaboration,
you have your architecture in place.
So...
Once you have an architecture in place,
then you got to make sure you assure
conformity.
So the architect or his or her
representatives will be available in the
project right through to make sure that
architectural conformity is assured.
There's a tendency for developers to take
shortcuts.
and eventually the project has to pay for
them. The business context.
The moment we talk about business context,
we talk about return.
Over investment.
You.
The Chief Executive gives you a long
lecture on security.
You come back to him after five days and
tell him, yes, sir,
I've given due thinking to this matter.
Everything you've got required is going
to be done.
It's going to cost you $10 million.
And the CEO tells you, relax. OK,
let me think over it.
Can you explain why you will be spending
this money? What will you achieve?
And then, instead of...
You are being told what to do.
You are explaining to the CEO what is the
meaning of what he has asked for.
The CEO takes a trouble to understand the
meaning of certain security requirements,
which he or she had just rattled off as
jargon. So
And then...
He says, okay,
what am I going to get returned?
What is the benefit of the security?
you convert it into dollars or rupees and
say, okay, this is what the value is.
Then do you need to invest?
What is the risk?
What are the type of losses?
What is the implication of those losses?
What's this going to cost the company in
terms of market share,
in terms of trust by the customers,
in terms of loss of repetition if these
things happen?
What is the probability of these things
happening?
So these things are all taken into
account.
And then there will be compromises. Okay,
we'll do this, but we won't do this.
This will probably achieve.
We'll save some money here.
So the moment the architect and the
business leaders start discussing these
details,
we are talking about the business context.
Professional context is capability.
What we understand, what we can achieve,
what is good for the company,
what is the future.
Who are stakeholders?
Is very easy to understand that the
customer is a stakeholder.
And mostly people tell you customer is
the stakeholder.
The developer is also a stakeholder.
The maintenance person is also a
stakeholder.
The finance person is a stakeholder,
maybe third party paying.
The government is a stakeholder.
So the number of stakeholders and every
stakeholder needs a representation.
And sometimes you find out that just
because you ignored a certain stakeholder,
eventually the project is not going to
work because the needs of the stakeholder
are not satisfied.
Even when you decide not to address the
requirement of a particular stakeholder.
The stakeholder has got to be explained
why it is not being attended,
what is the priority of requirements,
what is the business expectation of the
company,
and while you are investing on what you
are investing,
what are the attributes which have been
given priority?
Who influences the architecture?
the development organisation,
the architect.
the environment in which you will use it.
So this architecture.
how it is influenced,
and the architecture itself influences
future architecture.
So this is basically what the next few
slides are about.
So I'm just going to flash through that.
Business has got goals.
And NFRs.
As had very rightly stated by Yahar,
are basically quality attributes.
And in this course,
the quality attributes we'll talk about
are testability, maintainability,
we'll talk about security,
we'll talk about performance,
we'll talk about availability,
we'll talk about interoperability,
extensibility.
These are some of the quality attributes
we'll be talking about.
And each of these.
Has got to be miserable.
Now, once you the business goals,
we very casually say that what the
business requires is the functions. No,
the business requires non-functions.
That's where the money lies.
A very, very important quality attribute,
which in today's world.
cannot be ignored. In fact,
it has in the last 10 to 15 years,
it has gone from last in the batting
order to number one.
Anybody taking a guess?
You can type it.
is not there in this list.
Security.
Security is there in the list.
Oh.
Cloud is not an attribute.
Cloud is an infrastructure.
Is something which all of you are.
massively concerned about the moment you
touch an application,
it becomes important to you. Performance,
you've already taken up. Performance,
Performance.
VYSHNAVI.
availability, sick.
So...
Is is it availability?
Availability we have already written here.
Sir, is it accessibility?
The XP.
Here it is, here it is: Kaushik, Kaushik,
Kaushik, Kaushik, Shreya Chowdary.
That's it.
Yep, so.
Usability.
Okay.
Companies are spending huge amounts of
money on UXUI.
Usability.
Usability has certainly emerged in the
last 10,
15 years as the number one quality
attribute.
Your application,
the user will look at it within 5 seconds,
decide whether it's worth to go further
or not.
And the user doesn't bother about
security, performance, availability,
nothing else. Just looks at the site.
It's like looking at the cover of a book
and you keep telling people,
don't change a book by the cover. But.
Damn sad, people look at the cover,
whether you like it or not.
And this is coming by recommendation.
Even if it comes by recommendation,
they don't like the look of it,
they'll say,
I don't know why that person likes it,
it's useless. So how usable the site is?
How usable the application is?
It has emerged as a very important
requirement,
and the amount of research being done on
it, people are doing research on fonts,
on colours, on placement of objects,
on functionalities,
the way the functionalities work,
the user model, the...
task model, the application model,
understanding these and documenting them,
making decisions about them,
and then the customer will spend any
amount of time discussing them.
In fact,
usability takes centre stage over
functionality and over everything else,
which should be very important.
So this is something which we will
definitely look at.
And then many business goals have got
non-architectural solutions out of our
course.
We don't have to bother about this.
Some business schools.
are directly issue architecture,
they've got nothing to do with quality
attributes. Few, there are few over here.
So just because of the nature of the
application, the functionality required,
you require a certain architecture,
very good will do it.
But largely speaking,
architecture has got to do with quality
attributes.
Professional contexts.
stakeholders.
We talked about.
Sir, can you give an exam?
Example of.
Yeah.
Not architecture.
Non-architectural.
Just a minute.
business goals which have got nothing to
do with architecture.
Um, okay.
The business wants to employ the best
advertising agency.
To make sure that the mind space.
of the customers is engaged towards the
product.
So they want to make good social media
advertisements, good TV advertisements,
newspaper releases.
The objective being getting mind space.
You know, mind space.
Has become a major concern these days.
Ohh.
Slightly out of context,
but I'll tell you,
when we used to study management way back,
we used to say money.
Material.
Manpa.
And machinery.
These are considered four Ms that any
manager had to manage. And they said,
if you had good manpower,
the famous example was given of Henry
Ford, the owner of Ford Motor Car Company,
who says, you take away my money,
take away my material,
take away my machines,
leave my manpower with me,
I will rebuild the organisation.
OK, so, but these are the four.
factors which made a new organisation.
An organisation needed money to run,
it needed material, machinery, manpower.
Then gradually, you know.
There was a realisation that movement was
very important.
When you say moment,
we are talking about time scheduling and
timing.
If you don't do something at the right
time, you miss the bus. Time to market.
There's a particular time,
if your product is released at the time,
it's valuable, you release it,
one month after that,
nobody's going to look at the product.
Okay,
so people started timing their decisions.
The moment became important.
In the last few years,
particularly with social media,
there's a 6th M that has come up,
called mind space.
And a lot of research is being done on
occupying the mind space of the public.
If you see colour, you should think of us.
And Jensen and Nicholson.
It's a paid company.
If you think of a phone,
Apple would like you to think that
anything other than an iPhone is a
compromise. So they feed it into your,
they want to programme your brain that
way. So mind space. So for that,
you would,
you want maximum mind space in your
prospective customers. You want to
Hire an advertising agency for that has
got nothing to do with the software
architecture. OK, so...
The person is the...
A person is giving you a lecture on
designing architecture for that,
you will probably tell that person,
you will let us know after you consult
your researchers on mind space as to
where we need to put in what to insert,
we'll put it in.
But don't ask our architects to think
about it, we are not capable. Okay.
So for that answer, I've taken a very,
very abstract example,
but there are lots of things which have
to be done,
which have got nothing to do with
architect,
nothing to do with the software also.
They simply,
these are non-architectural solutions.
So business schools,
whenever you are developing a new
application,
the business leaders have to present the
business goals.
Yes, so I was moving forward.
Business, technical,
project and professional influences on
the architect. These are stakeholders.
Professional is the knowledge of the
architect, influences the architecture.
The architecture influences the system
that is developed. The system in turn
Influences the architecture that will be
on a subsequent slide.
Is this context explained? Here it is.
The architecture and the system,
they in the next loop they will again
come back to haunt the architect.
Now, let's talk about this bit.
Now, all this well said,
why we need architecture,
what it architecture, and see,
today is an introductory session. Now,
we'll be going into all these things in
more detail in future sessions, so...
You have a structure and you have a view.
We must distinguish between a structure
and a view.
It will probably be understood best by
some of our database designers if I tell
them a structure is like a table.
And a view is like a view.
Create view, so and so from this table,
join that table, this is fields.
So view is what you see,
structure is what exists.
So...
Santhosh, do you work on data?
You talked about data,
it came to your mind.
Yeah.
Yes, sir,
I work on both data as well as you.
Okay, so when you work on DUTTA.
The difference between a table and a view
is view is what you show and table is how
you actually store your data, isn't it?
Yes, sir.
Okay, so similarly, there is a structure.
And a popular example given is of the
human body. The human body,
you can think of yourself.
There's a structure.
But when you see the picture of a human
body,
normally you have a photograph with
clothes worn.
Yeah, you are looking very smart.
You have an injury and you go to the
orthopaedic.
He suddenly shows you a picture where you
don't recognise yourself.
You know which picture I'm talking about.
If an exhibit only shows your boots.
Right? That's a view.
And that view is a view of yours.
But that is relevant to this particular
doctor.
You go to the cardiologist and he gets an
ensure done on you and shows you the view
of your body,
how the blood is flowing and where it is
getting constructed. That's another view,
the cardiologist's view.
Similarly.
You have a digestive problem and we run a
capsule through your intestine,
which takes a full mapping of your
intestinal structure.
The endocrinologist comes out with a
diagram of your intestine and tells you,
see this place, you've got a perforation,
this place is slightly bad.
We might have to, we'll give you medicine,
but we may have to operate.
A completely different view,
so views are the ways different people.
will be able to understand architecture
when you show it to them.
So we as architects draw view.
We as architect design structures.
So, Ashutosh, you can appreciate that.
Absolutely.
As a database designer, you design tables.
And then you present the view to the
developers.
Okay.
Now,
there are certain patterns which we'll
study later,
and what makes a good architecture is
what satisfies the requirement of the.
Okay.
Software Architectures system of a system
is a set of structures needed to reason
about the system,
which compromise software elements,
relations among them,
and properties of both,
properties of the elements and the
properties of the relations.
So, what elements you will have,
how those elements will be related to
each other? So, there is one element here,
one element here,
they are related in some way.
This is a husband, this is a wife, maybe.
So.
This whole thing put together is the
architecture.
So what are the properties of each of
them?
What is the property of the relationship
married on so and so date,
had so many children, whatever it is.
I'm taking a totally.
Unparalleled example,
but basically this is an architecture;
this is an architecture of a.
Family.
Of a unitary family.
Or we normally call it a nuclear family.
Architectures is an abstraction.
It is not the actual system.
It is just conceptually you are
presenting what the architecture is.
Every system has an architecture.
You may hear a comment, oh,
that system doesn't have an architecture.
The architecture may not be documented.
Document may not be there.
The architecture may be bad.
It may be a bad architecture.
But it is an architecture all the sense a
bad architecture is an architecture.
A non-documented architecture is also an
architecture.
So.
Every system has an architecture.
It may not be documented, it may be poor,
but it's an architecture all the same.
Behaviour of a system is a part of the
architecture.
You got to describe not only the
structure but also the behaviour.
Like we in the previous definition we
said the elements,
the relationships and the properties of
both.
So, there are many definitions.
You can.
Concept is structure has to exist.
These are various types of structures.
You can look at it as a module structure,
component connexion structure,
allocation structure,
and there will be various ways of
presenting views to show these structures.
Module is how you can divide it into
various coding units,
component connectors are elements and the
runtime behaviour,
how they interact with each other,
allocation is.
CPU, file system, working team,
teams that are developing,
teams that are handling.
So this is the allocation structure.
So these are the very three types of
structures.
So here the details are given of the
module structure.
units of implementation.
So typically you can have a client,
you can have a server.
You can have a meal server.
You can have an MS server.
Whatever it is.
You can have an IAS.
That's relevant.
And modules have got.
specific responsibilities.
And work is assigned to them,
so you may have a module.
Very similar. See, you may say that,
then what's the difference between...
A module structure and a component
connexion structure. This has got modules,
then they interact with each other.
We call that a component and connexion
structure. Here,
we have each module and what work is
assigned to the module.
And in a very large system,
you may have modules.
Initially, you develop, say, 2 modules.
We call it client, we call it server.
Then you may say in the client also,
I will divide it into components.
I may call this a UI,
I may call this a business logic,
I will call this the data link layer.
And in the server,
I might have the listener.
and we have a computational unit,
and we have a cache, various,
you may further subdivide it.
So, as the architect develops,
he may develop 2 modules first,
and then start breaking up individual
modules into sub-modules,
and sometimes the sub-module can be
divided into sub-sub-modules.
Component connector is.
The way they interact, see,
I've got this system, this system.
What is the interaction? Is it on soap?
HTTPS.
How the interaction will be handled?
What will be the protocol?
You might have to write down the if there
are some internal components,
you might have to write down the detail
communication protocol between them.
This is a runtime structure that during
runtime,
how they will they communicate with each
other.
So.
component is that way a runtime entity.
Then when the programme is running,
which are the components that will exist
and how they will run.
We come to allocation structure,
organisation, development teams.
installation team, execution team.
So which team will be assigned for
responsibility? Among the developers,
you may have various teams of developers.
UI business logic database.
security layers.
So each team is allocated certain
responsibility after the architecture is
set up.
The architect has decided what modules
will be required and based on that you
allocate and then you hire people,
you train people.
So, this is called a location structure.
No.
A structured architecture if it supports
reasoning about the system and the system
property.
So if you can describe the system
property through this structure,
it's an architectural structure.
attribute of the system that is important
to the stakeholders.
The stakeholders should be interested.
If stakeholders are not interested,
we are not interested in that
presentation.
Functions achieved by the system,
availability of the system,
the face of fault.
difficulty of making specific changes to
the system,
the responsibility of system to
responsiveness to user request,
and anything else,
any details about the system,
if it tells any feature about the system
which are of some interest to
stakeholders,
it's a part of our architecture.
So why do we call it an abstraction?
Because it's not the actual system.
It is just a representation of the system
in a diagrammatic form or in a written
form,
whereby you commit what will come into
existence before it comes into existence.
And when you say an abstraction,
an abstraction is a theoretical
definition
of an item structure and capability
without actually building the item.
So that's an abstraction.
So architecture is an abstraction.
Every system has a software architecture.
Is it good or bad,
whether documented or not documented?
It includes behaviour. Architectures,
not just the physical structure.
The way it interacts, what it does,
is a part of the architecture of the
system.
Physiological structure,
I just explained to you, orthopaedics,
haematologist, dermatologist,
they all see the same system differently.
The system is reading the same,
some diagrams too show to you. See?
This could all be.
Ashutosh,
from this diagram you can't even make out.
Then we come to structures and views.
A view is a presentation of a coherent
set of architectural elements as written
by and read by stakeholders.
So view is something that the
stakeholders will understand.
The architect has designed a structure.
As we presented a survey.
Yeah.
No, again, a couple.
How the system is structured?
We are repeating this in a way,
giving a little more detail,
module structure,
component allocation structure.
The structure provides insight.
It tells you exactly what you will be
developing.
Now, we will take up some.
useful module structures.
One is a decomposition structure.
Decomposition structure is just breaking
up the system into individual units.
some modules we call it a decomposition
structure.
User structure.
Is 1 module uses the other module?
So.
There's a dependency involved when you
develop an application.
Your C# programme may use.
NET as a dependency.
So, C uses.net,
so there could be usage and what.
In Java, you may be using Sprint.
So there are two subsystems.
Even the subsystems you design may be
using one another.
So this is a user structure where you
demarcate modules as one module with
another.
It may help you to develop an
architecture because then you might.
Put each module into a separate subsystem.
Then you have layer structure.
Dear structure is a system where you
divide this application into...
layers where the upper layer can use just
the layer below it. So you have...
Communication through proper channels.
So, typically, a kernel,
a virtual machine, these are layers,
the TCP IP.
TCP IP,
those of you who are involved in
communication,
they understand the TCP IP stack.
Those are layers where one layer uses a
layer below it and you achieve a purpose.
There are lots of benefits in doing this
that will be subject of future discussion.
Then you have...
class or generalisation structure.
You have a class where you generalise the
capability you can have.
Two subclasses.
This subclass may give be a
generalisation.
And you may have.
SONAL.
You may have various car models, C1, C2,
C3.
which are basically SUVs. So,
these are SUVs, SUVs, these are sedans.
So, you may have various models of sedans.
All of these are cars.
So common feature of a cars are defined
here.
Any specialisation to make it an SUV is
over here.
Any specialisation to make it a sedan is
over here.
The various models of sedans are
basically specialisations of sedan.
Various models of SUV are specialisations
of SUV.
So, demarcating.
A structure in this way would be called a
generalisation or a class structure.
Car is a generalisation,
this is a sub generalisation,
this is a specialisation.
This is a specialisation. Okay,
please note everything that I'm writing
on the slides will not be available on
the slides which are there in MS TEAMS.
If you have to see the writing,
you have to go to the video.
Then, data model.
static information structure,
how you will store the structure,
the way Ashutosh designs this tables is
the data model.
Even the database that he designs is
dependent on how the application will be
running.
He maps the application into the database
so that the data is available in a form
that suits the application engineer.
Then we come to component and connexion
structures.
So, what is the service structure?
whereby there are consumers.
And their producers.
Services are produced by certain service
producers and this consumer errors.
So this we call it a service structure.
Concurrency structure is where you can
divide the job.
You can fork it out and be done
parallelly, and then you merge it.
So this is how you show a concurrency
structure,
where you'll allow two activities to go
on side by side. A typical example of...
This type of structure, most AI models,
large data models,
they run a number of processes together.
You got the MapReduce,
which is a very popular.
Approach in Hadoop.
I don't know how many of any any person
here working on Hadoop.
Exactly hard server on Spark.
Are you aware of MapReduce?
Just like advanced version of.
As an approach, and Lindsey, yeah,
just tell us from your practical
Yes, like it's a first framework.
experience,
just to share some practical anecdote on
it,
so that that will be a way of sharing
Yeah.
some practical experience, yeah.
Okay.
No, sir,
I don't have a work experience on
MapReduce or Hadoop right now.
I'm using Spark for data engineering,
Yeah.
Look.
but what I learned is this MapReduce is
like a starting base created by Google
based on which this Hadoop and Spark have
come out.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
So we'll be going into details of it
later. But in essence,
what is happening is, you know,
why this has become necessary is that
suddenly there's an explosion of data.
In the last 10, 15 years,
the data has grown to such an extent that
it's not possible to write programmes.
which can process data at the speed at
which it is being generated.
Are you understanding?
That is speaking, no?
Hello, HARI.
Was it?
Yes, sir. Sorry, I was unable to unmute.
Ohh.
Yeah, yeah, welcome. So, Harry,
what happens is,
you can appreciate what it means,
that your data has been created at a
Yes, yes.
speed faster than what you can process.
So, how will you ever process data?
So what you do is,
instead of the data coming to the
programme,
you send the programme to the data.
So.
Wherever the data is,
any number of copies,
you send the programme there,
and the programme will extract the
essential part based on certain algorithm.
And only the essential part will be
collected to be processed.
So,
this is a fantastic concurrency structure.
So, if you want to show concurrency,
you a component and connector structure
will show that these operations are in
place concurrently.
That's what we mean by a concurrency
structure. OK.
Yeah, yes, sir.
Yeah,
so we just quickly run through the
remaining pages.
Implementation structure.
how modules are mapped into the file
structures in this development
environment is something like how you
create subdirectories and how you create
packages.
For your for implementing your working
work assignment structure.
Would be.
Signing them to TEAMS.
So these are allocation structures.
This is a physical allocation to machines
or to subdirectories.
And here is mapping them to people as to
who will take on the responsibility.
Now,
structures can be related to one another.
It's not as if they exist independently.
Like in your body,
your circulatory system,
your nervous system, your skeletal system,
your endocrinological system,
your reproductive system,
your respiratory system,
they all exist in the same body.
They refer to the same part.
A heart exists for everybody.
The cerebral exists for everyone.
The arms exist for all the structures.
So these structures,
though we study them separately,
they actually coexist,
they relate to the same item.
So that's what is being brought out here.
And there are a few diagrams here,
which will brings out the correlation
between modules and components.
Then architectural patterns we'll be
studying later.
These are standard ways of tackling
problems in a given situation,
which will give you the results that is
desired.
So,
we'll be studying patterns after the
midterm exam.
So process rule,
product rule for getting good
architecture,
some rules of thumbs you can go through.
And with that,
we are exactly one minute left for the
class to be worth.
Component connexion service in
concurrency. OK, we can explain that.
Uncle next time you remind,
we will touch it again.
Yeah, go routines and channels. OK, good.
Go concurrency.
So I think it was nice meeting up with
you all and I look forward to.
Being with you again?
See you next week at the same time,
same place.
Thank you, sir.
Mail ID is, yeah,
I'm very poor at responding to e-mail.
In fact,
I will tell you that it's best to try to
catch me in the class,
that also in the beginning of the class.
But I've got no problem sharing my e-mail
ID,
but don't be too hopeful of a response.
Yeah.
The best any issue to be taken up with me,
catch me in the beginning of the class.
If you take up something in the beginning
of the class, how nice of you.
Wishing you a good night. Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
And wishing you a good day.
****.
Yeah.
Bye.
I said.
Bye, bye.
I'm just switching on the recording. Yeah,
Thank you, sir.
bye, bye, bye.
Set it.